if I think about like the 15 years that
I spent working in this industry
what has changed really is how fast we
need to take actions
and that's another reason why I believe
the market or the today's modern
marketers job on the brand side is very
difficult because they're relying on
agency partners or their internal
in-house agency to prove success and to
optimize their dollars which is a fair
ask but it's challenging
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
we're gonna kick off from the exact same
place I'm very excited for you to be
here thank you very much for having me
thanks for having me as well
wonderful so so Sasha tell me a little
bit about your story how did you get
into this space from the beginning a
little bit about a little bit about your
journey from your eyes so uh I first
started my career in affiliate marketing
which is basically a way to incentivize
and come and save people that have
content blog posts websites putting
advertising on their space and getting
them paid basically if they deliver a
sale so that's where I started 15 years
ago
um at that time I worked at an agency in
Boston Massachusetts I worked on
exciting accounts uh Adidas I worked on
Phillips I worked on TracFone and I just
like fell in love with the people I was
working with the culture was awesome
people were friendly there was beer at
1pm sometimes on a Wednesday which who
would start to love about that and then
I moved to Germany and I started a
career in digital media planning so I
got to learn a lot about you know how
audiences are set up and create given
media and it just made me really fall in
love with this industry and choose a
career in it
that I I love it okay and what's sort of
been the the if you're looking back at
the main milestones for you throughout
your career how would you describe those
those big step functions that you've
made so I think moving to Europe was one
big milestone and I see how advertising
is different in Europe and Germany
specifically
um two years later I came back to the US
and I started working at an agency here
um I dropped around a few agencies here
in Morton a variety of accounts I think
I've worked on maybe 40 different 60
different accounts in my career uh wow
so now I'm just working in different
continents at different companies but
also working with a lot of different
clients from all kinds of verticals
thinking you know about financial
services technology stamping Gene food
really get to understand how different
businesses and different business models
are reliant on Advertising to drive you
know sales are an impact so very
exciting time in my uh you know career
in the last 15 years working with a
variety of different people and
industries as well
and so what does it mean to be senior
vice president of media and performance
analytics what what does that even what
does that even mean you know
strategically in terms of what your job
is well strategically I get to work with
a lot of really smart people
um and those are people on the agency
side on my team on other teams that we
work with like creators and account
services as well as a lot of clients
um my role is overseeing a team of about
65 people and those people are experts
in their in their domains and
advertising as a whole but from the
media side you know this is essentially
the way to find audiences and deliver
creative or messages from a brand
um on the performance analytics side
this is all about measuring the impact
of what we just did in media so
beautiful media Right audience targeting
let's say on Facebook or on a cable
network or watching your favorite show
on Hulu or on Netflix Netflix is getting
there it's not quite there yet they just
started monetizing
um that's the media and then of course
the creative is delivering the message
the banner ad the Facebook post so those
two things in media and performance
analytics are married uh in my group
because we not only need to plan
strategies and launch them but we also
need to measure what they did and that's
for performance analytics is so
critically important
and so you're responsible for that whole
chain from the media planning to the The
Briefing of how well that media did
respectively to what you were planning
for it exactly so let's think about you
know from a real world example a client
comes to us and says hey I'm selling you
know I'm selling shoes online
um here's my budget you know 10 million
dollars I need to reach these types of
audiences
um you know give me a proposal so we'll
go and plan a media plan around that
Greece and deliver them a recommendation
so the first stage is planning and
strategy and then once that's approved
we launched the campaign and that's
called activation and then the third and
final State just optimization so this is
where the feedback loop starts to come
into place
um we can measure what specific
advertising did on a user down to the
user level if it's e-commerce it's a lot
easier because you can track someone's
behavior from the minute they were
exposed to an ad and that is called an
impression action all the way to when
they added the pair of shoes to their
cart and then they you know went to the
Shopify page of the Commerce site click
checkout and then the shoes get to their
house we can track that pretty perfectly
in the digital world
but in the physical world it's a little
bit more difficult
cell yeah
no no I'm sure okay so know where are we
at you know from from your perspective
they're the big opportunities when it
comes to to exactly what you're just
talking about so you know we're in the
entering February of 2023
what what's happening in this market
what's happening in the scene a lot of
things are happening and it's not just
specific to this month but it's been
happening for a long time in advertising
uh which is a very Dynamic industry
things move not by the day but by the
minute sometimes
um and there's a lot of different
variables that create change so if you
think about the advertising ecosystem
you have three players really to
simplify it you have the people the
consumers you have the brands and um and
you know the suppliers so that's the
three part of uh the three parts of the
ecosystem the agency sits within that so
the agency's world like where I work at
amp agency
um our job is to essentially be
strategic Consultants on connecting
Brands to Consumers
and within that ecosystem there's the
suppliers as well so depending on where
I want to reach the consumer I can work
with Facebook I can work with Google
I can also work with bostonglobe.com
um so where we're at today there's a lot
of change and I think that's been true
for the last two years especially
um but we're entering another year of
unpredictable behavior in the market and
that's uh not anything new to us
especially in the US you know we've seen
these moments in time so 2008 we had a
recession
we saw incredible change in the
advertising space with various Brands
you know dialing up Amazon spend by 28
and decreasing newspaper spend by 27
um in that time and then we'd have to
covert which you know started about
three years ago here in the US
um but saw an incredible just change to
how people are interacting with media
right everyone started using social
streaming video like crazy where people
stopped doing was going outside and
therefore out of home and Outdoor
Advertising took a Plumb it temporarily
acid live sports which were paused so
today fast forward three years what
we're entering is another year I think I
think of dynamic uh volatility so
from an ad agency standpoint you know
we're seeing this as uh Brands will be
very fluid and flexible with their
budgets and how they spend and where
they spent they will need to be
um really understanding where every
dollar is going what that impact of that
dollar is so not anything new to us per
se but something that we are entering uh
optimistically cautious I would say this
year
yeah how do you and your old keep up
with the with the you know biggest you
know the the bigger Trend technological
Trends to be able to do with these
optimizations and to be able to to have
a rigorous analysis of of what are the
right mediums because it sounds like
your role as a strategist is to be able
to to leverage information in order to
understand how Brands connect to people
and then what are the right tools to
help them do that and then so obviously
these tools are changing and
personalized ads are changing and the
whole go to market approaches have been
really different and I can only imagine
what's happening now with chat Bots and
if you have some thoughts about that I'd
love to hear them as well but how do you
you know Sasha keep up with with all
these different advancements and changes
so a few different ways I'd say me
personally and then my team is
incredible at keeping up with uh ongoing
Trends um in a few different ways so
um what I'm looking at Daily is the news
and when I say the news I'm talking
about uh industry use right we have a
lot of great Publications like adage
digit day media posts that are you know
pumping out lots of content
um from editors from experts in the in
the space so just keeping up with
industry Trends is very important
because as I mentioned this industry
evolves by the minute sometimes
um you know you open up the front page
of AD age or digit day and there's a big
merger or a big acquisition that was
just announced and you know um I
remembered this example a few months ago
when Netflix uh said that we're gonna
officially offer a paid tier and start
add an ad sport a tier which is massive
news
um so I think you know looking at Trends
um on the news but also talking to other
experts so my team is really great at
connecting with vendors on the supply
side
um as well as our brand and our client
partners and just having a discussions
um mobile privacy is an ongoing topic
right it started with gdpr it then
progressed to
um to other regulations so the mobile
space
um is really changing a lot and some of
it is driven I would say by uh by the
supply side like Google
um you know announcing the deprecation
of the third-party cookie a few years
ago which is now set for next year
um you know Apple's changed to iOS and
tracking and you know actually making
sure that people are opting into being
tracked
um these changes have massive
implications on the ecosystem and what
we can and cannot do from an advertising
standpoint so those two things I would
say are pretty important to be doing
very frequently is is looking at the
news and and the trends out there and
just having discussions with um with our
partners on you know at Google and
Facebook and also some of the smaller
suppliers as well
yeah it sounds like it so what is your
personal day-to-day like look like for
you uh very different every day I spend
a lot of my time working on new business
with my team and with um other folks at
amp and Advantage our parent company
um you know that's really the fun part
of my job I loved working on pitches
um I love brainstorming with others on
you know Creative Media ideas
um you know thinking about do we fly a
blimp over a building and have the
client's logo or do we do some kind of
crazy activation uh with that's outdoor
you know with
um you know with a brand client at EV
charging stations in Europe so that's
part of my day is working on new
business
um another part of my day is just
working with my team on operation so
figuring out the financial uh
performance of our of our agency of our
team if there are improvements we can
make from a resourcing standpoint to
make sure that teams are staffed
properly
um and then you know another huge part
of my job is just talking to clients and
asking Metro feedback uh and asking them
how we can you know what they think we
could be doing better
um that is probably uh the most
important part of my job right now
um
that's a really interesting point so
what did you find to be the most
important pieces for customers for types
of service that you provide for you know
what what do they really care about at
the end because obviously there's the
whole performance side right I mean
that's kind of trivial you know there's
been you know you have the Benchmark and
what you want but but how what do you
really in terms of the the you know the
expectations that perhaps are not as
clear or not as
um intuitive I would say what what have
you found from those conversations
um I think a lot of the success uh comes
or a success in a good relationship
between our agency and our client
Partners comes down to transparency
um and part of that transparency you
know has to do of course with pricing
and and where their dollars are being
spent
um and things like programmatic which is
you know has uh unfortunately been a bit
murky um in the past I think this
industry has made a lot of great strides
in transparency
um from a programmatic standpoint but I
think just from a fundamental level
transparency in a relationship
um you know and it's really no different
than than any other transparency would
have with your friends or partner or
anybody else right what's going well
what's not going well and probably that
second part is is more important than
the first but it's you know if
something's going well or not going well
the most important thing is what can we
do about it together right
so transparency is very important um in
that relationship are are the
expectations are there are there are
there expectations that are changing
over time that you find as as you know
we as the world of advertising and and
uh part and and brand awareness is
evolving and changing are there
different are there different
expectations that are changing I think
uh in some ways there are expectations
that are changing
um
as there are Evolutions that come out in
this industry uh for example
as media becomes more measurable
the expectation is that we can then
deliver insights faster to clients and
we can optimize campaigns faster so
beyond the algorithmic about a power of
Google Facebook you know ad algorithms
AI targeting you know cookie lists
audiences
beyond that real-time optimization of
campaigns there is an expectation that
we have all of this data the
expectations we need to collect it
faster we need to translate it faster
and when we translate it we need to
understand what it's telling us so that
we can make actionable optimizations
faster so I think just from a bar
setting standpoint the industry is
evolved War media is measurable in media
that was never measurable in the past is
becoming more measurable like streaming
video
and so therefore there's this
expectation that we're going to be able
to be much more Nimble and much more
agile in optimizing campaigns
so I think that's kind of the primary
Trend if I think about like the 15 years
that I've spent working in this industry
what has changed really is how fast we
need to take actions
and that's another reason why I believe
the marketer the today's modern
marketers job on the brand side is very
difficult because they're relying on
agency partners or their internal
in-house agency to prove success and to
optimize their dollars which is a fair
ask but it's challenging
from within your experience now what
what are the what is the bigger
Improvement that were that we hope to
see in our ability to measure you talked
about you know the the media ability to
measure as a core
as a core piece of our ability of the
evolution of of the you know this space
what is the next big step function that
you observe to be in the space
I think there is a few so
the trends right now are kind of
pointing to let's say uh somewhat a
volatile Market especially in the US
right so we're entering a potential
recession
we are still recovering from from you
know the tidal wave of covid
um so a lot of what the focus has been
on now is
how do we remain flexible with media
investment and do it in a way that we
can move dollars and optimize so beyond
the measurement of how is something
doing there's a need to optimize and
there are certain levels we can pull
and one of those levers is which
audiences we go after so audience
targeting right
um one huge powerful tool in the toolbox
is first party data so if you think
about the data ecosystem you know in
advertising language first party data is
the data that somebody owns so let's say
a brand
um
like Sam Edelman uh or Stop and Shop or
Ajo delhas right
um Apple delays is one of the largest
grocery brands of the world uh we're
fortunate enough to work with them and
they have a lot of first party data so
if you go grocery shopping
um what are you buying how often are you
buying it what times of the day are you
buying one item and then you're buying
the next item right so a basket Builder
item
um so being able to use that first
parting data which a brand owns and
target audience is either new audiences
that we haven't discovered get them to
come to our stores or Target audiences
that are existing and get them to buy
more and just spend more so that's one
powerful tool is the first party data
third-party data is data that the brand
does not own so this is data that let's
say Google has on your search Behavior
so being able to use the best
combination of first and third party
data and it's a kind of find new
audiences do it strategically without
spending a lot of money and doing it
cost efficiently that's a very big Trend
that the industry is looking at right
now and there's things like clean rooms
that are being developed where a brand
can take their data they can merge it
with third-party data to find new
audience segments if they do it in a
clean room right they do it in a way
that the data is not being shared
um in a in a let's say
you know in an unethical way in a
non-privacious way
yeah no I think that's a
it's that's a really interesting um
take on something that I've been
thinking about a lot recently myself so
thank you thank you for bringing that up
I'd love to wrap up and the episodes
asking you the core question of why do
you do what do you do so sort of like
why you know you when you actually you
know reflect back on on what you're
doing and know what what it means to you
what what is it
that that makes you enjoy what you're
doing so much honestly uh the people I
work with
um and I mean the people on my team and
people are my clients uh side that we
work with
um you know I I feel like I've worked
with some of the smartest people I've
I've known in my life here and you know
day in and day out I'm talking to new
people or you know folks on my team or
folks on the client side that are just
so smart in in the world of advertising
but a lot of different other subjects
Beyond advertising so I feel like I'm
constantly getting my brain stimulated
with new information and learning a lot
and
um I think that's one reason the other
reason is solving challenges for many
different kinds of clients so I I
mentioned you know an example of a
grocery client aval Dil haste that we
work with
you know working with clients that are
selling checking accounts or brokerage
accounts or clients that are you know
large social networks
um you just feel like I'm always kind of
learning and how to solve these
challenges with advertising so
two reasons why I love N2
Sasha thank you so much for a great
great episode and uh thank you for
sharing with me your story I I really
appreciate it and I'm wishing you best
of luck and continue enjoying what
you're doing and thank you for coming
and sharing with your parents thank you
for having me it was a pleasure thanks
so much